Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jamie in South
Dakota. Jamie, you're on the air. What's going on?
Speaker 2: Hello? David. Can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. Um, I'm, like, kind of like a
capitalist in, like, the Nordic kind of moral
sense. Okay. And I know you're from Argentina, and
I was just wondering if you followed, like, any of
the like the leftist wins in, like, Latin America?
Speaker 1: Yes, to some degree I followed
them. But did you have a specific question about.
Speaker 2: One of them? I was wondering if you
think like with the some of the talk of like
over, you know, like taking over like the market
economy, if like you think that they could like
turn kind of like that like this government would
be different than like the previous outcomes.
Speaker 1: Which government which government
are you talking about? What country?
Speaker 2: I don't know, just kind of maybe
like Chile specifically. I don't know.
Speaker 1: You're saying if
Chile could overthrow capitalism?
Speaker 2: Very like to earth. Like he's
talking about, like doing different things to,
like, get make it more kind of public and like
more like more socialist and get rid of,
like, the market based stuff. Yeah. I mean,
I think that would be positive.
Speaker 1: Countries should do
whatever the people want their elected
representatives to do. I'm not a socialist
personally, so I wouldn't be advocating for a
country to become a socialist country. But if
Chile or whoever, if there's demand for it from
the people and it's not being imposed in an
authoritarian way by a, you know, authoritarian
of some kind, try it. Absolutely. Why not?
Speaker 2: Right. Right. Yeah. I'm just
really interested to see how it goes.
I'm not a socialist, personally, but.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, give
give it a go if that's what the people want.
Speaker 2: Right, exactly. Yeah. Well,
thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. You too.
Jamie from South Dakota. Great to hear from you.